what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four but we're actually gonna
Sidetrack from Hickman for a second and
we're gonna go back to Mark Miller
because with everything that's going to
be happening here in the next probably
week or two we're gonna be focusing on
something called new world and that was
established during Miller's run so this
is very important especially when we get
to the part about Galactus but the thing
about this is that this initially picks
up with a Fantastic Four doing Fantastic
Four stuff which is fine but ultimately
while we're at the Baxter building
you've got Janet Van Dyne you've got
She-Hulk who operated on the Fantastic
Four at one point in time and then of
course you got Susan storm one of the
things that kind of goes on behind the
scenes when it comes to the Fantastic
Four comics and when I say behind the
scenes I mean like in between fights
because the Fantastic Four are kind of
like the first family of Marvel Comics
everybody of course knows who they are
they're highly respected but it's also
kind of like friends who hang out with
each other so Susan hanging out with
like Janet or She-Hulk or other people
who have been involved in the Fantastic
Four is not uncommon but essentially out
of nowhere they're met by the arrival of
a woman named Alyssa Moy now this is
really interesting because when she
shows up she tells Susan like she needs
to get a hold of Reed Richards right she
needs to speak with him directly but she
isn't really giving them any information
as to why it is now one of the things to
know is that Susan storm is aware of who
Alyssa Moy is and in fact Alyssa Moy can
best be described as like the female
version of Reed that in fact her and
Reed kind of had a little bit of a thing
when they were younger but Reed ended up
basically marrying Susan storm and has
been with her ever since now the funny
thing about this is that of course
Alyssa Moy is depicted as being
exceedingly attractive and when Reed
arrives she's like hey so like we need
to go talk about something um there's
this project that myself and basically a
guy named Ted Castle have been working
on Ted Castle being like this Ultra Rich
billionaire and we want to show you but
we can't tell everybody what's going on
because it would create problems and so
where Reed ends up leaving with Alyssa
because Susan storm doesn't really care
the funny thing about this is that Ben
Graham you end up finding out Susan
storm does care because Ben Grimm in a
room full of women
makes this statement that like man
Alyssa is a lot hotter than I remember
she's like 10 times hotter than I
remember her being now here's the thing
if you are a guy you do not tell a room
full of women one of which is married to
the to a particular guy who's leaving
with this chick for some kind of a
science mission that the chick he's
leaving with is basically hotter than
all the girls here you just don't say
that kind of thing but the kicker about
this is that basically Reed is taken to
what is essentially a giant oil rig and
when he gets there he ends up finding
out that it's not actually an oil rig
instead it houses what is in effect a
portal to a different place and when he
gets through it he's taken to a place
called new world that what's going on
here is that Ted castle and Alyssa Moy
along with basically the world's richest
men all came to this realization that
the Earth itself will be uninhabitable
within like 10 years climate change and
all that kind of stuff right that the
Earth has been around for five billion
years or something like that it took
Humanity like a hundred years to screw
it up right and so because of that she's
like the Earth is not going to be
inhabitable right like the Earth is a
place that we can't live anymore and so
once we came to this realization we
started working on the new world project
and so basically the world's richest men
are bankrolled really richest
individuals men and women are
bankrolling this entire project we've
got some of the greatest scientific
Minds in the world working on this and
there's only like 400 people who know
that it's actually happening and we're
just now telling you about it now of
course the most logical question has to
be asked here why don't you tell people
about this and it's like because human
beings are human beings read if we go
out there into the world and we say hey
everybody the Earth is screwed in 10
years because you guys all screwed it up
people are gonna panic but people are
just going to experience this massive
existential dread they're gonna freak
out and they're basically gonna start
looting and everything is going to go
nuts right human beings are going to do
what human beings do in a time of panic
and so as a result of that they haven't
told anybody the scale of this project
is astronomical right they've taken
trillions of photos of just the city of
New York itself right not to not even
taking into a count all the other places
and they have perfectly duplicated the
world all the way down to the graffiti
that's on the walls right just one of
these things where it's just a massive
undertaking now they're not too far away
from it or at least from completing it
but the reality here is they want to
bring read on board they want him to be
a part of this now the other part of
that and these are really the kind of
questions that have to be asked here is
well how's this world going to work if
we literally bio engineer a new world
and then nothing ever changes in terms
of like governing and how people
function and so on and so forth we're
gonna screw this world up in like 100
years so like what steps are you guys
taking to basically fix all this and
that's when you learn about a program
that's called the cap program and the
idea behind this is that it's kind of
modeled after Captain America to a
degree but the overall gist of this is
that it's an acronym for conserve and
protect and that this guy would
literally patrol around the world and
basically take away any weapons that
anybody has right like any giant arms
Armament things like that so it's
basically forcing peace on people now
human beings being what they are are
history 3 being what it is Humanity
would somehow find a way to wage war
most likely however what they're
pitching here is this notion that if you
are going to live on this world you have
to cast aside all those old issues the
problem with that is some of these wars
that are being fought are being fought
by societies that hold blood feuds that
are so old they don't even know why
they're fighting anymore they just know
it's always been that way and it's the
way that it always will be right like I
hate you because you're from this place
and we've always waged war against
people from that place and that's just
how we do things right I mean a lot of
ways humanity is primitive in that way
but the reality here is it's an effort
to basically curb the destructive nature
of humanity as a whole now what we also
end up learning is that there are
basically Nightingales in every single
Hospital which serve a purpose of also
offering a humanitarian aspect from a
hospital perspective right they have
What's called the world Banks which is
basically a sentient AI that essentially
guarantees or at least argues that it
can guarantee a stable economy for at
least a thousand years they've taken a
variety of different steps and order to
make sure that this new world can
actually function and so what ends up
happening here is that once Reed
Richards is sent back to the Baxter
building of course he can't run around
telling everybody this he does record
some of it for his own interests his own
personal gain but then what you end up
having here and this might this is going
to seem out of nowhere that what you end
up getting here is basically this girl
named Cindy we never learned her last
name but she's basically kind of like a
robber and she ends up just sort of
sparking a relationship with Johnny's
storm a lot of that's because Johnny
Storm kind of loves the forbidden fruit
right that kind of a thing where she's
like a small time bank robber and it's
one of those things where Johnny's kind
of like hey like I like the bad girl
right I mean stop robbing banks but like
I like the bad girl and let's kind of
see where we can we can take this right
that sort of thing and it's a very
passionate right very just hot and
heated relationship and that's
essentially it now there is a side plot
that takes place with the cap robot
basically escaping confinement and then
showing up in the world and then just
literally doing everything from or at
least starting with like disarming and
dismantling like nuclear stockpiles
across the world the concern is that if
it keeps going without being stopped
eventually it'll just track down anybody
who's a hunter with a gun or anything
along those lines and kill them
ultimately it's defeated and so the
concern here about cap escaping is that
the world would become aware of like new
world and all that kind of stuff for the
most part it's not right just once the
cab robot is taken care of it all just
kind of gets sucked under the rug so the
general population is none the wiser
about what's happening here and so what
you end up getting are a couple
different things the first is a
revelation that's established by Alyssa
Moy that she never got past Reed
Richards and that in a lot of ways she
was always sort of jealous of Susan
because Susan storm was the one who
ended up marrying Reed instead and she
actually makes a move and tries to get
Reed to leave Susan's storm behind this
was kind of bookending and sort of
leading into the notion of like the
Council of reads from Jonathan Hickman's
run where for one reason or another Reed
always leaves his family that kind of a
thing except the main Marvel Universe
read is basically the one who doesn't
but the other thing that happens is that
with their life being busy and hectic
and Susan storm launching her own kind
of Charity different things like that
the wedding they end up doing is hiring
a nanny and the woman who at least
responds to an interview or at least is
supposed to have an interview is a woman
named Tabitha now she will become
incredibly important over the course of
this story but the thing behind this is
that Tabitha of course being here and
basically waiting for Susan has spent
time with Franklin and Valeria and they
love her right I mean she's like the Mrs
Doubtfire of this Fantastic Four story
they absolutely adore her but before
Susan Storm's able to arrive and really
even meet with Tabitha in the first
place Dr Doom invades the Baxter
building now unlike what you would
expect where Doctor Doom shows up here
with the intention of just tearing
things up and ripping things to Pieces
instead this guy looks worse for wear
man this guy looks pretty abused like he
just got the crap beat out of him and so
when he shows up here it's really more
looking for help than anything else now
of course you end up having Tabitha who
grabs you know Franklin and Valeria and
basically takes them to where their safe
zone is supposed to be or at least
Franklin is one that leads them there
but the thing behind this is that you
have Ben Grim who initially deals with
Dr Doom but is suddenly met by a group
who were calling themselves the new
Defenders now we don't know anything
about these guys but we will the kicker
behind this is that Ben Grim is a guy
who's gone toe-to-toe with like the
Incredible Hulk on a multitude of
occasions this guy's on par with Thor
depending on what era of comments you're
talking about with Thor suffice it to
say this guy's more than enough to
defend the Baxter building on his own
the new Defenders take him out like that
it's this guy called LightWave that
literally just eliminates him in the
blink of an eye he doesn't kill him he
basically just sends him flying out of
the Baxter building at that moment they
end up grabbing Dr Doom and whisking Dr
Doom away and so from that point it's
like where in the world did this guy go
like what in the heck is going on here
now the other part of this is that when
Johnny Storm basically breaks things off
with Cindy and the two of them end up
going their own separate ways of course
she's seemingly heartbroken by all of
this but the reality of this is you
switch over to where Doctor Doom is
being held now the crazy thing about
this is they keep talking about a kind
of source of power they keep talking
about how they need Doctor Doom and in
fact there's one of these kind of com
conversations that take place where
they're like is the plan working is it
all coming along is it supposed to and
one of the individuals basically says
relax everything's going according to
plan and it's the Incredible Hulk right
so whatever's going on here is basically
being lead uh being led by The
Incredible Hulk but here's the thing
that I'm going to say not everything is
what it seems because what you end up
doing is switching over to Johnny Storm
when he's basically doing his thing and
he's suddenly attacked by LightWave out
of nowhere now LightWave is able to hold
his own against Johnny Storm quite
readily but then that's when Cindy steps
in and Cindy someone who actually has
psionic abilities and in fact she goes
by the name of psionic that she had
basically been pretending this entire
time she was never the person she
claimed to be and striking up a
relationship with Johnny Storm was
actually done for the purpose of finding
some way to overcome him secure him and
bring him to the new Defenders so she
was literally working for the new
Defenders the entire time now when
Johnny Storm figures this out and
realizes what's going on he's basically
assaulted by the two of them but neither
of them are able to overpower him
because Johnny Storm is ridiculously
powerful and in fact during Jonathan
Hickman's run we're gonna get what is
arguably not even arguably what is
definitively the best moment for Johnny
storm in the entire history of Marvel
Comics God it's so baller those are the
guys who read Hickman's Fantastic Four
you know exactly the moment that I'm
talking about it's ridiculously amazing
God I'm so glad we're going back and
remastering this but the thing about
this is that while these two are trying
to deal with Johnny and Johnny's getting
the upper hand on him you have what's
called a hooded man who seemingly comes
out of nowhere and overpowers Johnny
Storm and knocks him out and then as
soon as that happens Johnny's whisked
away to the to the base of the Defenders
now that's when things start to start to
clear up right that's when we start
getting answers to so many of these
questions that we have that what they're
talking about here at least with the the
new Defenders anyway is they're talking
about a machine they built right and
what we're told is this machine that
we're building needs real power and the
job that lies ahead you guys are good
but your main battery can be found down
there right beneath your feet literally
saying we need you as a source of energy
to a degree but the real source of
energy that we're going to be tying you
into and we're going to be using the
three of you for you're quite literally
standing on it and what we end up
finding out is they're standing on the
body of Galactus what ends up happening
is the Hulk basically speaks up and
starts offering questions what we end up
learning is from what it was that Alyssa
Moy had said when it came to the world
basically coming to an end that we're
told the world didn't come to an end in
10 years instead because of the fact
that Alyssa had met with Reed Richards
and told him the world was coming to an
end the actions of Reed and others
basically staved off the end of the
world for about 500 years but the end of
the world came anyway now when the end
of the world was nigh and there was no
conceivable way to basically stop the
end of things just due to like the total
collapse of the Earth's environmental
ecosystems right basically climate
change reaching its most logical
conclusion the wealthy and the powerful
disappeared overnight nobody knew where
they went to and that billions of people
had basically starved to death the
world's cities or at least those that
were on on Coastal Waters were basically
drowned in the ocean that literally it
was just a catastrophic Global Climate
end times right that's really what it
was and there were superheroes that
remained behind and there were
superheroes that tried to help people as
best they could but at the end of the
day it was a losing game it was only a
matter of time before disease cancers
things like that took what was left of
humanity and so what ended up happening
is the Incredible Hulk had basically
started working on a system that could
be used to essentially fix the problem I
mean even the moon itself was in
shambles right like literally torn
asunder now the other thing to keep in
mind here and this is something to know
this is not actually Bruce Banner
Instead This is Bruce Banner Jr now if
the question that you're asking yourself
is doesn't that name sound familiar it
should because Banner Jr was the little
baby Incredible Hulk that was saved by
Old Man Logan in the Old Man Logan
storyline yes this ties into Old Man
Logan and in fact we're going to revisit
this because it's really really cool
because we basically get the fight when
they took down Galactus and in fact we
get this really cool explanation of how
it all unfolded in the first place but
the important thing here is that with
this situation being what it is their
idea is okay well then are we just gonna
leave Earth and go to a different planet
the Hulk's like no we can't go to a
different planet there's not a suitable
place for millions of miles but we do
know of a place that we can go to where
we can like breathe the air and drink
the water and eat the food and so on and
so forth the intention of banner Jr is
to create what's basically a time
machine to send them to the past the
problem with this is they don't have a
readily available power source they've
stripped pretty much all the resources
from wakanda because we can largely
assume everybody in wakanda is dead they
basically took whatever resources they
could from attilan because the inhuman
sucks they're probably overpowered
pretty easily but the thing behind this
is they don't have a real power source
here the kicker behind all this is while
they were trying to figure this out
Galactus showed up on Earth to consume
it and that's when they realized we can
use Galactus as a power source and so
again the comic that we'll cover later
on is the one that takes place in
between this because we immediately just
jumped to Johnny's storm who's like holy
cow you guys overpowered Galactus like
you literally mugged this guy knocked
him out and now you're using him as a
source of power and their response is
yes because we've literally created a
time machine what we're going to do is
we're going to take 8 billion people
from the year 2500 in the future the
future that we as the new Defenders come
from we're going to teleport them here
to the present day now the crazy thing
about this is that it's like you're
going to it just completely destabilize
the entirety of the world as it exists
right now but the responsive banner and
Junior in them is like we don't care
like it's not our concern right we want
to live we have a right to life and so
ultimately we're just going to show up
on your in your present day era and
we'll find some way to make it work
right like somehow it's going to work
but the reality here is it's a
last-ditch effort now the response of
like of Cindy here is you also have to
see the bigger picture Johnny Storm like
if you were in our place where would you
not do the same thing and the the idea
here is that with them they're the only
ones like these new Defenders are the
only ones who really have the
wherewithal to save Humanity they're
doing what needs to be done and so
ultimately it's one of those things
where where literally Johnny's like okay
like what do you think Doom right like
would you do this is this something that
you think is reasonable and Doctor
Doom's only response is like I'll say
this whoever orchestrated this
kidnapping will die at my hand tonight
so swears Victor Von Doom and that's
when Johnny's like you hear that Hulk as
soon as Doom gets out he's gonna kill
you and the response Banner Jr is oh I'm
not the one leading the show I'm the
second in Command right I'm the the
technical guy the one who's leading the
show is out there switch over to Tabitha
and that's when Tabitha starts making
her move that literally Tabitha was like
okay everything's all sorted out Johnny
Storm's been taken Dr Doom has been
taken we have to get the Fantastic Four
off the board so she goes and she visits
Reed Richards and starts talking to Reed
and one of those things is kind of like
you know you should really tell the kids
what happened with Johnny and that kind
of a thing and through this sort of
conversation we end up finding out the
what Reed Richards has done is he's
basically developed this kind of serum
that basically injects Nanobots into the
body so that no matter where a person
goes in space and time they can be
tracked down by the Fantastic Four and
really Reed came up with this because
the Fantastic Four they can time travel
they have time traveled it makes the
most logical sense but realizing that
Reed is already up to this and that if
he uses it he'll be able to find the
secret base of the new Defenders before
they can execute their plan the Tabitha
takes out Reed Richards by bringing down
this giant piece of machinery and
sitting it crashing on to read and then
following that she contacts Franklin in
his room and says hey you're gonna hear
some noises out here Franklin
everything's cool don't worry about it I
have the machine set up so it'll give
you as much candy as you want and you
can watch anything you want on TV right
because Tabitha is aware of the fact
that that Franklin Richards can alter
reality and so keeping him distracted
and keeping him removed basically
ensures their plan can go off without a
hitch and so following that she ends up
coming across Ben Grimm and Jennifer
Walters She-Hulk and then immediately
incapacitates the two of them by
creating a force field and sending them
flying into the sky and so once she ends
up catching up to Susan and catching up
to uh Valeria that's when Susan starts
to realize what's going on here and she
picks up on who it is a Tabitha is that
Tabitha is not Tabitha Tabitha is
Susan's Storm from the future when
basically the entirety of society had
collapsed and that for Tabitha Reed
Richards and like Franklin and Valeria
that they had seemingly done what they
could now Franklin does not seem to have
gained the level of power that he would
gain later on when he became like a
universal shaper and a reality warper
and all that kind of stuff hence the
reason why Franklin was unable to save
the world because I know you guys are
going to ask that question but the other
part of this is given the various
Technologies of Reed that they were able
to prolong the life of the members of
the Fantastic Four at the very least
that seems to be the case but that seems
to be the explanation of why it is that
Susan is 500 years in the future and
isn't that much older now again we're
also kind of making some hypothesis here
because we don't definitively know if
she survived 500 years or if it was
jumping back and forth time or whatever
it is but the important thing is she's
more Adept at her powers than modern day
Susan and so she's able to overpower her
and when that happens she goes back to
the base of operations for the new uh
the new Defenders basically informing
them the Fantastic Four are now off the
board we don't need to worry about them
now what's really crazy here and this is
a genius bit of writing Reed Richards
puts two and two together those little
Nanobots that he created once they're
injected they can never be removed and
so he injects Susan's storm and the rest
of the Fantastic Four with those bots in
the moment here and out and using those
Tabitha immediately pops up on the radar
right Susan immediately pops up on the
radar now the question was asked like
how in the world were you able to do
that now here's one thing to understand
that when it comes to the Future in
Marvel Comics you comic writers will
come along and they will say this is the
definitive future so in this
hypothetical scenario right here or this
situation in 500 years the earth will
definitively become uninhabitable that
there's no conceivable way to stop that
that will be the definitive future of
Earth in Marvel Comics until another
writer comes along and says we found
some way to basically stop the issues of
climate change and the world is saved
and it's not going to end in 500 years
the reason why that matters is because
with that being the guaranteed future it
means it is guaranteed Susan Storm from
500 years in the future will come back
to the past and basically try to set up
events or create events where they can
use Dr Doom and Johnny Storm and
Galactus as a source of power meaning if
Reed injects Susan right now in the
present day with those Nanobots she will
have them 500 years in the future
because they can never be removed hence
the reason why they showed up or at
least he was able to find uh find Future
Susan in this point in time I hope
that's clear as mud but what it does is
basically just Mark Miller giving
himself an out and giving himself a way
to kind of get out of the hole that he
wrote of the base of operations for the
new Defenders cannot be found under any
definable means by anybody whatsoever
because Susan is at least capable enough
to outwit read Richards because she
knows what it is that he's capable of
that kind of a thing the way you end up
doing is of course having the Fantastic
Four that show up on the scene in the
new Defender is building and there is a
bit of a fight that takes place it's not
an overly massive one I mean it is cool
to see but one of the things that we
learn here is that this guy the quote
unquote stepfather of banner Jr is
actually Wolverine now it has not been
solidified that this is Old Man Logan we
can kind of allude to it to a degree
given the confines of the story it's not
until you get into Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four run that you learn that
is Old Man Logan but I kind of assume by
the time we get around to that you guys
will have forgotten so uh I decided to
include it here
to be honest with you guys but in effect
each one of these guys are basically
kind of taken out and defeated in
different ways and so the Fantastic Four
for the most part kind of come out on
top but they've constructed an alternate
plan because one of the things to know
here is that the new Defenders are
fighting for their survival and the
survival of humanity 500 years in the
future in order to bring them back to
the modern day that what you also have
is a Fantastic Four who are trying to
prevent that from happening but there is
a third option that there was a point
when Susan had dinner with Alyssa and
what Alyssa had revealed to Susan storm
is that she was lied to by Ted castle
that building new world and using the
intelligence of Alyssa in order to do it
was not done for the purpose of saving
all of humanity that in this 500 years
in the future when Banner Jr was telling
a story and saying the rich and the
powerful disappeared overnight it's
because they went to New World that
that's actually what it was being built
for it was being built as a place where
the ultra rich and the powerful could go
and basically continue surviving while
everybody else visually all the remnants
of humanity were just left down on Earth
to starve and rot and die and so when
that Revelation was given to to Susan's
storm she came up with a plan that what
they're actually doing here that where
she's literally fighting future Susan
and future Susan is like this is a fight
for survival like if you stop us our
people will die Susan's response is not
quite and what had happened is she had
worked alongside Alyssa to create a
teleportation system that with new world
having already been finished because
again it was going to be done like a
couple weeks or so so there's obviously
a bit of a Time skip here that with new
world basically being completed and just
waiting for the ultra witch to arrive
there whenever Things become
uninhabitable on Earth that what Susan
and Alyssa did is they teleported the 8
billion citizens from the far-flung
future on a dead world to the present
day on new world and that's where they
reside now it pisses off Ted Castle to
no end because it basically destroys all
the plans that he had and of course all
this money as far as the rich and the
powerful were concerned was completely
and totally wasted because none of of
what they had shot for is actually
coming to fruition but the important
thing is that this future is safe right
the people in that world are safe now
this story may seem like it doesn't
necessarily have a point it does because
this will become ridiculously important
later on down the line during Hickman's
Fantastic Four run but as for future
Susan because the question now has to be
asked how can you have two Susan storms
running around at the same time the
answer is that you don't right that
Galactus is basically destroyed right
this is Galactus from the future that
he's basically destroyed this is
something that I want you to be aware of
or I want you to keep in the back of
your head because this dead body of
Galactus will be Revisited during
Hickman's run it's one of the other
reasons why I wanted to cover this
because if we didn't do this and then we
jumped into that story it wouldn't make
any sense but basically the body of
Galactus is dead it's just sitting down
underground deep deep beneath Earth and
then what you end up having is Susan
storm the future Susan who approaches
Victor Von Doom and apologizes for
having kidnapped him but Dr Doom
maintains his promise remember he said
whoever orchestrated this kidnapping
will die at my hands tonight and so when
Susan storm approaches him to apologize
he completely incinerates her right just
kills her on the Spock and when
everybody's like what did you do man he
was like I restored my honor I kept my
promise only a fool would kidnap Doctor
Doom and expect that there would be no
consequences for it but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching we
will pick up next week back with
Hickman's Fantastic Four and I will
catch you all later
peace